After Kakao Talk
[Music]
, I don’t have much confidence and my self-esteem seems to have increased. That’s right, I’m speaking
Korean, I’m 25 years old
, and I’m already long. I’m now majoring in cosmetic pharmacology in graduate school.
Hello, I woke up with a bamboo salt
10 cg 1 * 2 o'clock seems to be over, but the
cam moon and several doors are excellent Eyes Sook 2000 I really did
a little bit of death penalty using foundation or concealer, and then I just
had a problem.  When I showed my skin and used 4
or so, my confidence improved a bit, so I covered it up a bit and put a little on it, so my self-esteem increased and I
was able to deal with people a little more without hesitation.
is we looked out their sig to get used to the king
Chris in Force Dairy Prospex forgot as a non-Ikea non-
Korean, basically, since Korea is a little bit smaller, only the main ones tend to focus on it, and
the memo is also competitive.
In the past, there were a lot of women underlining, but now, whether it's a woman or a man,
you need to
take care of yourself a little less and look a little better.  I think
it is because it can and for example cows can get a little more popular in that kind of problem in the mountains
bsm downs make-up market for AIDS give them on their
encounter on spec had gotten worse had tube m james more
foreign 4 men among preferential  There are people who want the enemy, but I think
most people
like the look of a little sagging feeling
when they are the same.
The enemy is saying that they are increasingly focusing
on this kind of thing, not lectures on august Manual Shiny Steps The more I write the goal, the more ink I get, the more I lose, the
more I kissed.
After that, but when I look into the future, I have a little social experience and then
I create my own brand in
the country.